hey Internet did you know that you can
see live breaking news over on our new
channel screen junkies news yeah you can
do that including the new Wonder Woman
trailer reaction so click below to check
it out and now without further adue
screen junky show what's going on guys
Doctor Strange hitting the theaters it's
the sixth major comic book release this
year that got us asking the question are
we going to be suffering from a comic
book movie fatigue we're going to
address that very question right here
right now and we're gonna talk about it
with a couple of movie aficionados comic
book fans and all-around swell guys ah
coming across the hall again our good
friend you're gonna see them on screen
junkies news and you got a brand new
show debuting Monday November 7th 4 p.m.
Dan's labyrinth whoo what a jerk he's
Plus and he's a good friend of the show
he's been here several times you can see
him on geek and sundry's brand new show
dick and Johnson welcome back sax car
hey good to be here ah great to have you
so from 1980 to 2000 there were close
around 30 comic book films uh 20 year
span in the 20 year span uh from 2002
the upcoming 2020 80 plus comic book
films so guys are we currently in a
comic book movie fatigue I think that
there's some elements of early onset
fatigue I think if you look at the
box-office a lot of these movies aren't
performing quite as well as some of
their share Assessors um but I think
really what we're suffering from more
than comic book movie fatigue is
unoriginal movie fatigue and that's
unfortunately something that plagues a
lot of comic books it may also be
blockbuster fatigue - is it comic movies
or is it really the sort of capes and
costumes big giant punch em ups those
are the movies that I think are sort of
you know drifting away maybe a little
bit now before we go too far down the
rabbit hole of experiencing fatigue I
would go in the other direction and say
we're kind of lucky to have been in a
golden age wouldn't you say absolutely I
mean we were talking before if you look
at you know the early 2000s there was
one or two every year 2008 I think it's
either people kind of keying on Iron Man
The Dark Knight both huge for Marvel and
DC really launched those into the
mainstream huge hits launched franchises
that were saying
this day but there is diminishing
returns especially you know these movies
are hard to steer sometimes you're going
wrong you don't know it right away and
you hit a couple of icebergs well but
those were coming on the tail of what we
also thought was another comic book
fatigue when we were looking at the
spider-man films in the x-men films and
films like daredevil that all were
during another time when comic movies
sort of were on the rise miraculously
and yet somehow we were sure they were
gonna go away and then two more movies
came and lit the match again you look at
those early comic book movies and the
one thing that you do see in that early
batch your Daredevils your Fantastic
Four's your x-men the last stands to
some extent is you see the audience
willing to go see a movie
generally regardless of quality that's
what a lot of times you look at this
first two fantastic four movies people
wouldn't saw him and they were awful you
don't get that this was all after blade
to blade was one of the first successful
comic movies ever and that was so good
and so surprisingly good you kind of
always hoped that every and blade was a
nothing property to and you were like oh
daredevil that's another comic no one's
really heard about I'll go check it out
it'll be great it wasn't great No yes
not but nowadays you get a fantastic
four that is a little bit DOA when it
hits the box-office and it doesn't
perform because people are like oh yeah
I have other superhero movies that I can
go see really what we also talking about
Spielberg said that he thinks comes with
movies do like westerns right there's a
bunch of them right now and they're all
gonna die out and of course Disney and
WB are terrified of that I think that
Marvel and Warner Brothers actually I'll
give them a lot of credit right now are
doing I think to battle this idea of
fatigue Man of Steel I think fell into
this Iron Man to definitely fell into
this this idea of we're gonna put a
superhero in it and throw a bunch of
noise at the screen and people will go
see it because it's a superhero movie
and I think they both realize that
that's not necessarily the thing Warner
Brothers agree with the direction that
they take it or not they have given
their films a distinctive style I think
that Doctor Strange has a distinctive
style I think that ant-man has a very
distinctive style
and I think that's the key for these
movies to continue going on they're
realizing now that you have to kind of
transcend the comic book movie tag and
make these movies their own genre my
thing is I think it'll be it's much more
believable to me that studio executives
will actually have a more realistic
money goal then the movies will stop
being made because you look at something
like Batman versus Superman which is
considered somehow a failure but bra
a billion dollars yeah and they're like
that wasn't enough you know and I mean
and I can see where they wanted it to
like you know sort of become a cultural
touchstone and it didn't but at the end
of the day that like that they're gonna
eventually say you know what we would
take a billion if we could make five
more Batman films and they all made a
billion dollars we'll go with that it's
not going to stop making these films
they're just gonna stop expecting them
to make a trillion dollars and that you
know and and and and maybe hope every
few of them do what could be the death
knell what could hypothetically kill the
comic book movie a perfect example that
would be Josh Trank's Fantastic Four
mm-hmm the idea of studio think I think
that comic movies could easily die out
if the studio's treat it I think I get
it that it's a product but if they take
to create a voice out of it josh trank
you know what he was doing the Fantastic
Four in that first two-thirds of the
movie I'm not gonna say it was good
necessarily but it was interesting and
it was different right may have been
misguided we never got to see how the
resolution of it because the studio
stepped in and trashed the last third of
that movie made it just the blandest
most generic like you look at the last
act of fantastic four josh trank and you
look at x-men apocalypse right that's a
comic book movie that every studio wants
to make because it's got big action
right it's this deep the characters
don't have anything to do it's easy to
sell in every market across the world
they've made these heroes so iconic and
so powerful in these actors so famous
and when they put them all in one movie
it's very hard for them to balance the
time and so as they get more and more of
these movies having more and more of
these characters it might be possible
that they just lose track of how to tell
a story what you have to do is tell a
few of those characters that they're
going to take a backseat
but sometimes Studios can't and then if
you give everybody five minutes all of a
sudden there's no film left you
basically a clip show of the best of
your your own movies I'm going to throw
this out and ask you guys want one final
question
sure if you could give the studio's all
the studio's any piece of advice
regarding comic-book movies to avoid
comic book fatigue what would you say
it's simple with tell story I think that
if you look at successful film
franchises the ones that maintain
whether it's Lord of the Rings or Harry
Potter which are kind of in the same
space it's that the last installments
did the best critically a lot of times
and at the box office because it was the
end because people wanted to see how the
story ended
and I don't think it does anyone any
favors to make all of these comic book
storylines endless because then it's
just the idea of why should I go see
this movie it's just setting up things
for the next movie and I don't want to
invest an endless amount of time and
that's not just common with movies I
think that's the same for Star Wars I
think that's the same for just about
anything is don't make these you can
make a bunch of comic book movies that's
fine but tell a story three or four at a
time and then start a new story my
suggestion would be to look more into
ground level superheroes I mean John
McClane is a superheroes as much as
Superman is if you think about it he's
in every day every man here but there
are a lot of low power to no power
heroes and comics that I think it
overlooked by the studio's because they
don't feel like it's a superhero film
and they have some of the best stories
because they have to work the hardest
Studios listen to these guys hey what do
you think are we going through comic
book fatigue or you sitting there saying
what the hell are you guys talking about
I'm having the time of my life let us
know in the comments section below
we want to know I got to thank these two
fellows Dan Merle don't forget to check
him out on the new screen junkies news
and on sj+
with Dan's labyrinth and sack scar check
out dick and johnson on geek and sundry
and check me out on twitter hit me up
thanks for watching I'm how Rudnick bye
bye hey guys did you know that this end
card works with your phone now I know
right click the boxes below to watch
more screen junkies videos and click the
screen junkies logo to subscribe and get
this show honest trailers movie fights
and more